Democrats with eyes on retaking control
of Congress promising to continue
investigating Brett Kavanaugh even if he
is confirmed to the Supreme Court
there's a whole investigative process
that can and should take place and you
know what this is such bad practice that
even if they were to Ram this guy
through as soon as Democrats get gavels
we're gonna want to get to the bottom of
this you can't ignore a crime victims
claim that something happened refused to
investigate throw her up into the stand
without the least bit of support for her
without the least bit of effort to
corroborate what she says and then walk
away from that as if you've behaved at
all properly in the New York Times
getting a lot of attention for this
op-ed making the case for ditching
Cavanaugh if he gets to sit on the High
Court okay Jessie yes it seems like
there's a long list of things Democrats
want to investigate if we if and when we
take the house back in November do you
think this is a real serious threat or
just an empty threat well he's a liar
because he doesn't want to investigate
no White House he doesn't want to
investigate they the Democrats on the
committee had their chance to
investigate and go behind closed doors
an interview Brett Kavanaugh and they
were invited by the majority Senate
Republicans on the Judiciary Committee
and they abstained and now they're
complaining and they say they want to
investigate well you had your chance
you're obviously not an honest broker in
this process they're also doing it to
rally the base obviously and who knows
you know if they do win the house or the
Senate anything could happen it's all on
the table impeachment not only of
Kavanagh but of President Trump and I
just think he was speaking the truth
there I think they're honestly going to
go it all in on this administration all
in Dana do you think this I mean
Democratic voters are very fired up
we've seen that the base is very excited
to vote how do you think that message
plays we're what 45 days to the midterms
well it repeatedly what voters say is
what they want is they want Washington
to get stuff done right if you are
campaigning on only doing investigations
of the president and his administration
that spells one word and it's gridlock
so you don't actually get to what the
voters say they want it might be what
the Democratic base wants it might be
something that they want
you know they want to fight but it's
interesting is how the Democrats seem to
be flailing because they know that for
three decades they're conservatives work
together to figure out a way to find
really good nominees like Brett
Kavanaugh and Neil Gorsuch and John
Roberts and Justice Alito and Amy
Coneybear
I mean there are there is a pipeline of
excellent conservative judges and the
Democrats have blown this issue off they
didn't care so instead of actually
winning elections so that they could put
somebody on the court they just want to
impeach and investigate which is pretty
unsatisfying especially if you want to
go to Washington to do some good stuff
Greg I think that we also hear from
voters that they want some
accountability for the Trump
administration that they don't feel like
the Republicans in Congress are doing
much oversight of the Trump
administration which I would agree with
but what do you make of this oversight
we've been subpoenaing the deal we're
gonna get the DOJ in a second but they
haven't I mean compared to the kind of
oversight they've provided to the
administration I worked and it feels
different let's put a very transparent
administration Murray I'll say that
first let's investigate Cavanaugh
because after after he's confirmed
because then your party would be able to
prove that this merely wasn't political
that if they really believe this and
they believe it with all their heart
they should investigate him they should
if they should go for him after he's
been confirmed because it'd be as if he
gets confirmed and then you never hear
about this story again what do you know
you know that it was a hundred percent
political and while we're investigating
you know who else should be investigated
who was the person that had a Chinese
spy for twenty years as a driver yeah
and then while that was happening her
husband got rich in China it was like an
honorary consul or something that's max
I'd be a 20-year driver who was a spy I
think Diane Feinstein should be
investigated as well hear hear all right
I've solved a lot of problems here a
very interesting theory though that if
Democrats are really not just being
partisan they will actually continue
investigating
even if he's confirmed Morgan what say
you so interestingly I was talking to
someone at one of the Republican
committees about the polling and
typically what you see whenever you have
a party that's controlling the White
House and Congress voters tend to want
to vote another party
power so that there's a
check-and-balance right this is natural
in the process what what the pollster
told me is that while that there is an
element of that that's happening with
independence what's happened is because
the Democrats are running people that
are so far extreme to the left wanting
to abolish ice so she's about districts
is district so but but the point being
is is that that natural tendency of the
independent to go towards the Democrat
is now tempered by the fact that they
know that the voters don't actually want
a Pietschmann when you poll them they
don't want all of these ongoing
investigations they certainly don't want
impeachment of Trump much less at
Supreme Court justice so I actually
think that Democrats do themselves a
disservice for the midterms whenever
they run on this first of all it's
incredibly easy for the president to rev
up his base when he would say look
they're not even gonna impeach me
they're gonna try to impeach Cavanaugh
and me not to like a ready-made campaign
at all right there well and
interestingly Cavanaugh has really low
approval ratings for Supreme Court
nominees so well they've gone down in
the last week I wonder how that happened
defense even before these allegations
they were historically low for Supreme
Court nominee but we will see how that
plays out we will continue watching next
week we'll be crazy